- [Sam] The world is changing.
Technology is absolutely vital
to fast-forward these changes.
- [Man] Seven, six, five, four, three--
- [Sam] I'm Sam Bird, and I
drive an electric racing car.
(upbeat rock music)
- Formula E is a single-seater
racing championship
but purely for electric vehicles.
- Formula E is going to
be the catalyst for people
believing that electric
vehicles are cool, fun
and that they are the future.
- There's no other place in
the world where you can push
these technologies so hard
that you can do in motor sports.
- [Sam] Formula E is really
in the here and the now.
- Electric cars, they
are computers on wheels.
Not only do we have to develop
the hardware of the car,
for sure the motor, the inverter.
But also we have an awful lot
of software to be developing.
There are probably a hundred
different topics we can work on
to improve the overall efficiencies
of our electric racing cars.
- That's why our partnership with
Hewlett Packard Enterprise
is so important.
- Hewlett Packard Enterprise
have designed a really
bespoke IT solution.
It is able to condense the
amount of time it takes from
the data to go from the
car to the engineers.
We have reduced that time
from about two minutes
to 10 seconds.
That might sound marginal,
but shaving two minutes
of non-productive time
is absolutely critical.
- Racing is important not only
from a sporting perspective,
but from a life perspective.
I firmly believe the
Formula E series will make
more people on the planet go green
because the technology
from here will go into
the production line and make a better,
more affordable electric car.
- It's not so much about the
speed of the car themselves.
It's about the speed of
how our team operates
and how quickly we're able
to adopt new technologies,
and integrate them into our race cars.
- That's why Formula E is so important.
This is the catalyst of change.